yeah Korea is one of those towns Town
towns Korea is a place where I don't
ever want to visit because I'm not
kidding you no one knows who I am there
do you think that if you're born and
raised there you would have been a comic
still I think I would have ended up like
on one of those like five variety shows
like and just running with the outfit
and just running across the stage but I
don't think I would have been like a
huge actor what about you guys if you
were born raised in Thailand you were
born in raised Korea like what do you
think same trajectory stand-up comedy in
Korea it was almost non-existent until
the last few years so our stuff is
variety shows right a lot of like
Charlie Chaplin type of [__] and that's
our comedy this it's it's really witty
really quick and really fast I think uh
Danny Cho started doing stand-up comedy
and he started really putting the wave
out there which was really dope yeah I
love watching those photos I'm like it's
like he has a crew of people now oh see
what that fool used to hate me because
y'all got similar sounding names and
looks exactly no straight up I think
that's what it was I've always wanted to
ask him why like what did I do and I
think it's because when I first came to
La I looked exactly like him
you know my same everything yeah yeah
and I was just a younger person that
looked look that was me yeah
it's like straight up it's the same look
and like the weird thing is is like when
I when I you know Danny is right yeah
he's [__] hilarious he's Pongo
oh so put Johnny gone and Pongo oh
that's right on Google sketches yeah on
my TV you know who's Pongo well I only
knew that recently because I saw those
sketches again yeah that looks like
David oh that's what I did yeah
you oh my God that's crazy yeah he's on
the Mad TV Wiki dude oh wow [__]
Pongo dude
dude most racist are they the most
racist sketches you've ever seen okay
yeah hilarious though huh
look wow oh yeah yeah it's so similar
yeah
right
you know what I'm saying man
the reason why I did that was because
they were already writing me like
Japanese business businessman number two
right like Asian [__] so I go you know
what I'm gonna go the opposite direction
I'm gonna go real racial yeah I'm gonna
go real [__] up Asian you know what
the cartoony on my [__] up Asian
character that you did that had me and
my brother crying laughing blind Kung Fu
Master oh it's so [__] up I'm so sorry
that character oh he's sorry you have no
idea how many times I pissed my pants
watching that [__] it's uncomfortable
though no no it's not oh
it's like the most like a grandized
exaggerated [__] ever yeah
it's classic
so good
look at this no audio and it's hilarious
[__] right here yeah
so you can hear the audio if you put
headphones like Baron holds man that's
so funny
do your eyes bad
[Laughter]
oh yeah I laughed so much at that
character it was so stupid and funny I
loved it it took five hours of
Prosthetics damn it was worthless yeah
just the head and the ah it was it was a
whole [__] thing
and also I couldn't I only used one
white eye because the other one wouldn't
fit I think I have one socket that's
like weird but that's hella funny man
that's so good if nobody has ever seen
they're gonna these views are gonna just
burst now because they're so [__]
ridiculous they're so I did a lot of
ridiculous things but at the time though
what else do you do you you know you you
sit there and they go this is what we're
gonna do yeah you do the best you can
with what they have do you look back now
and you're like I wish I would have said
no to some of this [__] no because I um
you know I have to say that I uh
I think that I was good yeah man I think
I was good on that show and I think they
weren't good it was groundbreaking [__]
a dog you're [__] amazing and I and I
can't believe that they allowed me to do
because at the end of the day although
it you know it is seems racist and you
know behind the times and whatnot it did
showcase my humor and my ability you
know I mean to do things and that's all
I wanted I think we kind of say the word
race is too easy now like I knew when we
say it in jest or whatever right like
you're you're Asian that's what I mean
so what's the problem what's the problem
you're making fun of I I still feel like
you know you're making fun of the
stereotypes exactly it's like when
Deborah Wilson played Whitney Houston
Whitney Houston right and you know or
Aries Spears would play another black
character right it's just like you're
just these are real people we're
portraying you know what I mean but um
you know I wish I I'm not a good
impressionist does that work now if you
release that video we just watched now
you think I don't think it's funny yeah
I think so because the joke isn't the
fact that you're Asian the joke is that
the Kung Fu Master is supposed to be the
wisest person in the room yeah and
you're a blind idiot that's why it's
funny it's not the Asian yeah it's funny
yeah it's the fact that you're over here
drinking a cup of poison
sitting at the bar yes I got the [__]
but also they would never write that now
right like you look at you know what's
the kid from SNL I like him but which
one yeah right he wouldn't he would
never do anything remotely like Johnny
gone or blind Kung Fu but he does play
embellish like gay flamboyant characters
yeah yeah same same kind of thing yeah
yeah yeah I know everybody's getting
canceled nowadays you also did the
average Asian I love the average Asian
skits oh that was pretty cool too yeah
yeah cause those those also like those
would like flip The Stereotype yeah yeah
all right if this is not up I don't want
my dick sucker he gets uncomfortable I
hate it man it sucks without you
can I see this though can I say this
then that's [__] turn the table yeah
all right Papa I'll tell you something
right now right
you know I was lost until you guys lit a
[__] torch in the forest and I could
see I got it oh
because I was lost fire you didn't plan
oh yeah yeah yeah see that but you guys
did so like people like you got that you
guys specifically yeah all right in fact
not you guys but uh yeah but nobody's at
all yeah but no but you guys
you got because you know when Hollywood
wasn't [__] with me I'm like how do I
survive right and you guys you mean
showed me the way hmm you mean your
generation so it's like um I'm grateful
as well nice try dude
I was crawling and now you're walking
what was the phrase
he broke boards in half so we can hire
that was it yeah we've been you know
there's never been an all Asian real
sketch show though huh no
no I don't think I would want it do you
want that though
um I just wanted to see one episode see
what it would look like let me do that
before it gets canceled yeah yeah no I
want to see what we could come up with
or you know what the angles would be
because
um and we wouldn't rely on you know
stereotypical stuff like but I just
wanna I'm just curious about I'd like to
see it would you want everyone to see it
yeah I mean I'd be down for that
no
he hates his own people that's no I love
I love my people dude but I mean we keep
it you keep the cast small like us three
and maybe two girls and that's it I'm
not I'm not saying that I would hate it
I'm saying like I don't think we need it
no we don't need it you know what I mean
yeah but yeah be kind of cool yeah but
let me I I think you do we do need it
okay we need it I'll tell you why
because it's I'll tell you why in
America because
um you know it's not something that you
see right and it's a skill set sketch
comedy for Asians it's not a skill set
you've seen on Prime Time right I see
what you're saying yeah I think that you
know if you did put one and put it on
his feet it was on a shower and that
works that it would I think people would
be wowed by it yeah I agree I think
maybe that those waitresses in Tennessee
will watch that show and be like oh it's
not hero every sketch yeah oh this is
not accurate you know yeah yeah yeah
hero is pretty accurate though hero is
it is actually kind of active it's just
how you do it it's just you know it was
Johnny yoon's uh opening line
who's Johnny Yoon
excuse me excuse me who's Johnny oh yeah
who's Johnny you duh
I don't even want to disrespect you by
explaining to this
that was Johnny Orlando it is a
character
or person or person that you portrayed
I think Johnny is a real person yeah
yeah yeah whoa can I just say shame on
you guys
but I know who Bobby leaves that's all
that I want to say this right shame on
you
oh Johnny you
were sad why did you say
Chinese stand-up he is a famous Pastor
he's a Korean pastor
Korean pastor
used to be called they call me Bruce
okay I've have you heard of it yes Bruce
Almighty yes
so anyway Johnny Yoon just a history
lesson yes uh was a comedy store comic
and he was around in the late 70s in the
80s right and Johnny Yoon we should know
this did a movie called they call it
Bruce that might me and my family saw in
the movie theater oh oh right so they
gave him a real movie a couple of them I
think and they call them they call me
Bruce and Tim not being like it's sort
of like the blind Kung Fu Master he's
not Bruce yeah you know what I mean
right and um were they good
did your parents enjoy it no one laughed
okay yeah in the theater I remember no
one laughing but I remember watching it
going
there's someone that looks like me
that's in a movie and I just never saw
that before and also people are speaking
English you know what's interesting I I
was talking to my older cousin
and I don't like it whether you shifted
but well I'm gonna go back to Johnny but
go ahead and listen to your story there
is a generational gap between like how
important representation is to people in
your generation versus I feel like our
little weird area no I disagree really
yeah I think it was super important for
me growing up okay I want to talk about
this right now but let me just finish
the job and then we can talk let him
finish this [__] point dog anyway
Johnny was what the [__] is yeah yeah a
chopstick comedy yeah it's a chopstick
comedy right so anyway as a stand-up you
know his opening line was he would walk
up in a tuxedo at The Comedy Store in
the main room you know and he wouldn't
say something for maybe a minute
and he looked at the audience and go
wrong and it would get a two-minute
Applause right
dude the bar was solo so low but anyway
that's that's who Johnny you should do
but go ahead finish yeah and so what I
mean by that is not to say that like
representation is important isn't
important in our generation but in your
generation there was a lot of
self-hating Agents where what do you
mean like they you didn't want your
asian-ness because you were made fun of
it for you know for ours like K-pop is
cool and all this other stuff and you
didn't have that in your generation so
when I talked to my older cousin he goes
I remember when I didn't want to speak
Korean or I didn't want to learn the
language or I didn't want to talk about
the foods that I eat but now that we
have social media and stuff you know
we're like there's always like a white
person like oh look at this a weird
fruit oh no you know in an Asian voice
yes
I don't know it was supposed to be
German but it came out weird all I know
is Asian I'm a Sherman I don't know I
mean look at this
about the piece yeah how do you like
that Whitey what was your point Tim oh
my point was um why to go off kind of
your point I I it was important for me
to see Asian representation growing up
and it's part of the reason why I even
got into entertainment in general
because I remember watching The Fresh
Prince my favorite show Growing Up never
seen any Asian dudes except for Dante
Bosco in a couple episodes and seeing my
first Asian guy on that show was a nerd
in the group of nerds and uh he was like
you know hey Carlton at prom like they
had like a little nerdy tucks on it's
like Carlton nice tux and I remember
even as a little kid being like oh this
is the first time I've seen an Asian guy
on one of my favorite shows and like I
know this doesn't represent me but how
is it for I don't know Alice in
Tennessee working at the [__] Alamo
who's never seen Asians at all she's
like oh they must be all little nerds
like this you know what I'm saying
because she's not exposed to it that's a
big reason why I was like let me get out
there and try and yeah you were hella
deep as like a five-year-old
but in the late 90s right I when I came
to La I had because what happened do
changes first are commercials ad
agencies change first and then Hollywood
follows right so I I I I remember like
going into commercial auditions and
sometimes they were like we want to see
Bobby first really yeah it was like why